we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
yo
whoa
what's up hey we might be drunk you got
that right we're on our way here with
this uh this it's martini day hell yeah
i mean we're going all in danny baby the
beard jew is already uh clinking some
cubes around and the then that grandpa's
cough medicine over there and if you
remember last week he said drink eat
bread with butter yes which we both
forgot yes uh so we've been throwing
down pretzels so we don't die here
pretzels one of my least favorite food
what i hate anything on a plane i've
hate i hate a biscott cookie i hate a
pretzel i hate it
i can eat a peanut but those are gone
you hate the biscoff cookie i haven't
hate it the biscoff cookie is is a
delight ah it's so hard you take one
bite
you dip it in your coffee
wow you get the airplane coffee oh i do
that's bad that's bad coffee with that
shitty cream or two nothing depresses me
more than a hotel creamer the powder no
well that's that's that's bottom of the
barrel that's like sars it's oh it's
anthrax right yeah
but the little
for some reason you don't need to
refrigerate it yes yeah the coffee mate
a little cup
pulled a little labia off of that thing
it's so and it bubbles up it's it's it's
chemicals like the labia i [ __ ] my
tongue in just so it doesn't overflow
yeah
uh i love that by the way when you get
the tongue in the hole
fun fact whoa coming at you hot oh my
god look at that that looks good all
right so this is vodka martinis because
mark uh mark [ __ ] up yeah
i forgot the kettle one it's sitting on
my coffee table i got a big jug of it i
keep it on the bar card it's my prized
possession and i left it at home like a
douche and so
danny boy ran out and grabbed it he's a
good barkeep this is all right well
cheers man that's a great
i love a martini it's classic i like
this glass better than the way better i
mean look it's classic i have some of
them at home and you know what i did i
got like it's like extra big so you just
don't fill it all the way up smart like
the you have to i hate it like you're
like [ __ ] why am i am i a jewel thief
why am i walking on my toes i know it's
less stable than a miami condo that
thing goes down with a
breeze so tell us what we got here there
apron so that is just a classic super
dirty filthy
uh vodka martini oh my god oh that's
filthy good and we're gonna agree with
this
is a lot better hell yeah is this just
olive
olive juice and vodka why is it so much
better than when i make it because i
made it
[Laughter]
it is damn good i mean the filthier the
better this is so good that is good
i like my vodka martinis like like
seawater or if i'm an italian or like
lots of water yes
totally and in a dirty martini there
should be no vermouth at all
in a dirty martini it should be either
dry or dirty i think so what is the
vermouth that's bisexual right there
pick a hole
pick a hole
what is vermouth what is the point of it
driver mouth it just softens it up a
little bit oh
well if you do a vodka martinis drive
vermouth with it right
that can be good i like absolutely but i
don't think that there should be driver
move in a dirty mart
[Music]
that's when people order like a little
dirty
that's like a finger in the butt not too
dirty it's not you're not getting pegged
right but it's it's dirty
it's a hint it's a hint pinky in the in
the stink
yeah this is good man this is damn good
and i like it dirt this is like uh
like louisiana water after that oil
spill it is gross
but it's good is this okay so this is
are you an olive guy yeah are you a
pickle guy yeah you like them both oh
yeah i kind of want to try those onions
and stuff back there too while we're
doing this because this is we get all
these you guys send us all this great
stuff at gotham studios and i love it i
love an old gay and uh we got pickled
red onion and pickled pineapple
what's the name of that brand on there
beer jew got old bay
no but i think somebody sent us those
at some company
three dogs pickles three dogs
there it is shout out to three dogs
love a three dog
three dog night
what do you got what's that one
all kinds of stuff here oh boy we got uh
spicy sesame and garlic i mean we got to
all try this right yeah this is like a
paula deen show we're gonna start saying
the n word and keep eating this pickled
uh
pickled delights
man you haven't heard from me she was
cancelled big cancel you know what's
funny about paula deen is all my black
friends and like black twitter is like i
like that bitch's chicken anytime [ __ ]
her she makes a b she can say the n word
while she's uh roasting up some gravy or
whatever the hell
well yeah but hey damn
paula dean yeah yeah yeah she really
went down i know and she was a big
titan in the cooking and empire yeah
damn she was like the southern lady he
had bobby flay you had emerald he was
i'm telling you like a hot guy who just
[ __ ] oh that's his whole thing where
you're just like this dude's just he'll
have guests on beat bobby flay where
he's like she's a young actress and
we're like we can read between the lines
we know how she got this fart i love i
would love to watch a sex tape of him
plowing uh giada de la renta who's that
is that her name what's that who i'm
talking about is that it but she's a
cute italian broad with a little
schneider yeah yeah so hot how about uh
nan batali went down pretty bad yeah but
that guy was everywhere those crocs are
empty
yeah i hate the living day in those
shoes
the bald ponytail how do you open these
you got it it's a ball jar this so i
have to like flip this up or something
uh yeah just
give it a little under the nails there i
don't have nails i bite my nails
i'll tell you
i told my psychiatrist i was thinking
about having suicidal thoughts now he
told me to pay in advance
my mom's a big foodie coos and she uh
she used to pickle everything when i was
a kid it was a nightmare i love pig why
anti-pickling well i i you know i like
eating it but i didn't have to own like
jar stuff i had to clean the jars and
help her like yeah i guess there we go
you got it yeah oh that's the pineapple
oh
man smells like an old cooter this
sounds this smells good
that is fire dude yeah
right that is really good
all right all right this is turning into
uh all right sorry i just saw it there
and we're like we're having this thing
yeah it was the food net we're doing
chopsticks all of a sudden
i watch val on your recommendation god
damn oh
what a tear jerker it's uh also my turn
for a bad hand job
it's incredible oh my touching yeah i
love them it's weird it's crazy when
they do that montage like they do all
the movies early on and they do that
montage of movies you've done you're
like man he's in a lot of bad movies i
know i know and he's good that's the
that's a [ __ ] up thing it's like i
mean and then he's saying like you can't
complain because he's rich all right but
then also the part where he he loans his
dad all this money and i know that that
was like brutal i know like and he was
in all that debt because he and then he
tried to make the twain thing i don't
want to give anything away you got to
see it it's on it the 20 thing is great
it looked great it looked great i
remember doing the road and being like
mark twain wow
oh yeah so his face with the stress
factor which i love he's such an actor
you know he was in that like shitty
little green room like how quaint this
is wonderful this is this must be how
they do no and i love the stress factory
calm down vinnie if you're listening but
uh
you know uh yeah
so many incredible things i mean there's
not to give too much away but there's a
part he's got a video camera he's just
documenting everything yeah so it's a
play you're talking about with kevin
bacon and sean penn yes and there's a
boat where he takes the camera out and
kevin bacon's like whoa is that a video
camera cool i know that shows how long
ago it's like the early 80s and they
look like kids they're probably like 19
20 21
sean penn still a badass you know it's
it's so important they still look scary
they all pull their pants down you want
to be like did he ask for their consent
to throw this up i know a good point but
that that was just kind of how it was
when you were like a young boy you just
did you whipped your balls out or
whatever i know and like i don't know if
you can is that toxic or if you were
near a governor either way
but i remember i went to catholic school
and guys would come up to your desk take
the balls out of the zipper and just put
them on the corner of your desk and
you'd be like all right all right all
right it was just pretty standard that
car looks [ __ ] good too oh man you're
gonna be stinking up a storm over here
i am all right i'm gonna be going
through a kiss later too i'll tell you
hey bring it on i tell you i told my old
man i want to go ice skating on the lake
he said wait till it gets warmer
don't go cuomo on me here
oh you want me to get in on this get in
you'll get there
that'll wake you up yeah that was great
i'm so good great wreck you got a watch
to die for watch that i will you're
gonna love it man val makes you realize
i don't know about your my parents
didn't videotape one
millisecond of my childhood and i think
that means i'm in good shape
you know
anytime there's a lot of video footage
of a kid he gets he gets kidnapped he
ods he gets in a car accident something
happens that's interesting right when
there's too much footage you're like
that something happened yeah definitely
or you become an actor i guess yeah
i mean his [ __ ] brother dies you're
like you knew something was coming when
he's like he's like i hate you can just
i've seen too many documentaries i know
when someone's like he was always more
creative than i was you're like [ __ ]
something happened to him he's gone
whenever he gets a compliment too early
yep ugh this is another one on an
intervention when they go he lit up a
room you're like oh he's on heroin
any time you light up a room your life
is ruined you lit up a pipe
uh no it's brutal uh i mean it's
i watched so many of those true crime
shows man yeah i watch them all i love
them i know the one i loved recently was
murder at middle beach oh
that was heavy hbo brings out the
bangers for that [ __ ] netflix has some
really good ones too but it's a grab bag
it's like one out of ten
hbo is probably like
eight more selective yeah yeah or seven
i mean i'll watch them all man the jinx
is still my number one
amazing uh a true crime where
there's like a there's a smoking gun i
mean i know in the the the the
confession is in real time i mean that
guy must be
jerking himself that guy came around a
lot andrew
farragut jarecki yeah he's a man he
directed bumping mics with that's right
he also did capturing the friedmans
i don't know silly billy silly billy his
dad was a pedophile he was like the new
york clown it's great it's incredible
all right shout out to all the women who
my girl gives me [ __ ] for watching
entourage and then she watches you know
the pedophile killed nine girls in a
hotel room with a garden hoe and you're
like all right entourage sends a bad
message what is this scent
exactly exactly they just bro hug this
guy [ __ ] strangles i know get off my
case here they're actors but jessica
alba's not an object yes she is she's an
actress
she's still walking this little girl got
gaped in a in a park and you're like
this is this is entertainment i mean
some of the footage not to give too much
away but uh when valkomber is
videotaping marlon brando he's like a
[ __ ] blob on a hammock this is
incredible and he it's his hero and he
won't answer him it's kind of like how i
feel with a lot of comedians around new
york you know there's like
what time am i on i'm like would you how
do you feel about that one special he's
like shut up
i i text colin quinn to be a part of
this uh documentary i'm making about the
pandemic yeah i text him i said colin
we'd do a part of this would mean a lot
to me and he uh he basically i'll do it
as long as you admit that no one wants
to be in your stupid documentary
and i said i said all right i admitted
he goes all right i'll do it yeah
it's like goddamn i don't know if i've
told anybody it's so hard but that's
that's and and you can't play we don't
want to do anything i know but you know
what it's his way of being like i'll i'm
cool with it yeah and he the fact that
he can be real with you shows that he
likes you and gets you and all that but
i love colin i had a few pops one night
i was on the road i was lonely i was
strung out and i texted seinfeld
recently that's probably about a year
ago it was like heart of the pandemic
you know everything's shut down you know
everything's weird there's a lot of
drama on earth and no one knew what was
going on so i texted seinfeld
two in the morning a couple whiskies in
ah
just talking about it makes my [ __ ]
pucker but i said
i got a great idea for a video cause
nobody was doing anything like it was
just like shutting down
netflix and chill all night yeah so i
said how about this
you like cars
we no one's putting out any content how
about we drive around empty times square
we get a film crew and you teach me how
to drive stick shift and it'll be funny
and he didn't write back for like four
days and then i was hungover like ah
what are you thinking why would he ever
want to do that it's such a bad idea
what does he get out of this it's all
for me i'm such a [ __ ] and then like
three days later he wrote back
okay
dot dot dot like kind of like
whatever no but
okay i don't know he wrote okay it was
very
vague
but
pretty uh pretty uncomfortable that's
brutal no no i mean we're still cool
we've texted since but that was like the
i learned a lesson i absorbed it i said
i'll never ask him for anything again
i'm lucky to have his phone number
keep moving
uh yeah i have one of those with leno
it's hilarious with leno yeah oh
hello let's hear it confession time
did i not tell the story on the podcast
not on the pod i don't think well so i
uh
i text him a few weeks ago just like i
saw his name on the line i was like oh
cool i know he's doing stand-up again
that's kind of cool you know well how'd
you get his number
let's go back to the beginning he just
called you out of the blue he i had a
publicist from my last special and i
guess he hit up my publicist like how do
i get i'd love to call him and he just
he called me to say he loved my special
i got this how cool is this crazy but
then of course i [ __ ] ruined it i
can't take a nice thing same uh he
he i text him because i have his number
i was like hey man i saw you doing stand
up how's it going how how how the sets
treating you or whatever and he just
said something like that's pretty good
that's all right and he said so long
lines is this like it's a guy who gets
too many texts yeah
exactly same with seinfeld you know like
you know he probably put this phone down
to be with his kids of course he's
backed like a hundred texts of course
and he's like
k
okay dot dot like that's what he's doing
yeah yeah
and uh
that's not so bad he wrote back
something along the lines of it gets
worse oh [ __ ] i said we helped me help
me uh learn a city bike around central
park and he he he waited four days
no he just wrote back uh
great
he goes oh good to hear from you sir
best wishes it doesn't answer the
question though
it's like nipping the like we're not
going further i get it i get it he's
probably he's a real man he's probably
underneath the car like yeah
wrench you know exactly he's got the
denim on with it it's not as bad as
yours that's [ __ ] crazy well that was
my i [ __ ] up with the text it was also
heat up pandemic like nothing was going
on it was so [ __ ] lonely i know and i
also thought hey you like count isn't
good you like cars i thought i was being
thoughtful but it was all [ __ ]
and uh he doesn't want to these people
don't want to do things you know all
they do is press junkets and movie
[ __ ] and all these like uh podcasts
and [ __ ] they don't want to sit around
with me doing a video for youtube i do
though all right
we're doing a bike ride we're doing a
bike ride yeah you know jerry uh he's
probably tired of course
he's like
any old guy who's in good shape like
that yeah
and they got a busy schedule do you ever
listen to him on tim ferriss no here's
good it's a great pod i text him about
it he talked about it but
he said he works out like three hours a
day every day seinfeld yeah then he does
tm so that so he's got his days blocked
yeah so to come shoot a thing would be a
whole hour workout he's a psycho man
he's crazy that sounds just horrible i
know i know he's got his he's got his
own demons but uh i like that jerry's
the last dude left wearing uh nike
vince carter in like 2003. yeah
it's amazing dude he's got he's got the
perfect uh old man wardrobe where it's
like it still kind of works jeans
t-shirt blazer yeah yeah with nikes yeah
he looks good you know what i think
about every time i see something like
that is there's a girl out there going
oh that's hot
some woman thinks that's hot it's a hot
look yeah it's just together it's
together he's like it's like being like
i'm i'm rich but
i'm cool i'm casual yeah yeah no i'm
with you because he can't go sweatpants
he can't go full
amber rose
juicy ass
you know full airport sweats with the
zip up that matches get out of here
carrying it in a jumpsuit and a [ __ ]
flat brimmed hat just like
just chill
nothing weirder when like an older guy
like even sandler has like a weird hat
cocked to the side or schwartzen i'm
like you're 48 you're 61. what are you
doing that's so sandler though
sandler still plays hoops like there'll
be videos that go up of sandler just
like some random pickup game and he's
he's not good either he's not bad well
he just come he's got like eight seven
foot eight black guys dunking and he's
like
yeah but he makes he's a smart he knows
how to pass he's a decent shooter
pretty good i told you about the time i
saw him on netflix what i think i talked
about this dave is the problem with the
sauce but uh i was pitching to get
netflix i'm all nervous i'm wearing a
tuxedo i'm freaking out and i see
sandler in the distance and he's got a
whole team around him his team is in
suits and blazers and everything he's
wearing a gigantic orange t-shirt that
came down to his knees crocs and
basketball shorts he he won he won he
[ __ ] won yeah unfortunately who's the
hope oh
it's a weird thing when you're homeless
you dress this way then when you're
middle class you dress better then you
put a polo shirt on and then when you
get super rich you go back to hobo yeah
weird how that works it is well it's
cause you you're trying
they say dress for the job you want he
already got the job
yeah the job is not giving a [ __ ] right
the job is making [ __ ]
grown-ups billions of dollars yeah
that's [ __ ] the dream you're just
making movies with your friends exactly
and my girlfriend thinks he's super sexy
because of that but she's like he's also
a good looking guy he's a good guy and
he's obviously funny and talented but
like
if you
were not successful and dressed like
that he'd be a bum but if you are
successful and dressed like that it's
hot it's funny how it all factors
yeah my brother-in-law is very very
successful and he dresses schlubby and i
like him i love it it makes me like him
even more because it's like
he's a really successful guy but you
know he's like
his out his shirts don't fit yeah i like
that about it i love it like you don't
give a [ __ ] i love that so dan soder's
on billions he's got the bonfire and
he's a touring headliner and
he looks like an eighth grade pothead
you know he's got like a slipknot hoodie
on and a hammer loop jean
you know dirty old reeboks i love that
he never left aurora in his uh in his
clothing yeah he's going to the x games
all of a sudden he's 61. i love him yeah
he's the best pull up if you can matt
wait we got no tv going here but if you
can't get get sandler in the last
special what is it called 100 tomatoes
or yeah something like that even his
outfit you know you know that sandler
put in a word for you me and liszt for
netflix for our
jokes jokes joke special i heard i heard
i was doing 20 each he [ __ ] made that
call which makes him
a hall of fame amazing dude totally for
me you got some uh interesting
connections i don't know him though i
just know
no way i mean i talked to him on the
phone once
let's hear about that what do you like
on the phone i never told you this you
did but i mean the people want to know
i just like wrote a couple jokes for he
never even used the jokes he used his
own i think he just probably wanted to
just like i'll get some people in but uh
did he see your special you have the
same agent or what are we talking about
i think same agency he just uh
watched he watched
he watched some uh clips of comics he
was like oh i like this guy so wow but
then yeah we talked on the phone he was
he was so cool i told him i remember he
was like uh you where do you work in the
city ever worked the comics trip out
there that's where i started you know
yeah and he was like oh yeah yeah that's
where i started man he's like i remember
he
he just asked a lot of questions you're
just like a really sweet guy and i
remember one point he's like your mom
your parents proud i was like yeah i
guess you know i was like you know it's
that thing where it's like my mom's
proud but then she's also like oh my god
i can't believe you're doing this [ __ ]
you know like yeah it goes from like
proud to being like horrified in the
span of seconds right you know like
example like you know getting a write-up
in hustler where my mom's like why can't
it be the new yorker or a vanity fair
you know yeah you take what you can get
mom yeah jeez uh but then
i remember he was like i told him some
story he's like your mom come out and i
was like yeah she comes out but i'll
tell a story and i'll see her ducking
her head down right
yeah i get that you know he was like so
we talked about that
he talked about i was just like oh man
you know is he normal on the phone is it
so nice
sloppy joe no i mean dude he's like i
love sandler growing up oh yeah that i
had the cds i'm dude those cds they're
all gonna laugh at you that like got me
that got me through some [ __ ] no that
made me laugh so hard as a kid yeah yeah
you better not do that again the the the
donkey or whatever oh yeah and then he
had the goat the goat and then he had
the uh the old man slotting down the
slide and he's like when his balls came
out i jerked off so hard and all the
friends are like what the [ __ ]
yeah
we all relate to that i know i know it's
great he's just so silly man we all love
sandlin man yeah any yeah it just hits
for us like by the way this is going
down too smooth two's i'm trying to hold
back i mean i can't hold back i got a
confession what this is the bomb i'm
gonna drop on you what happened so i'm
going to a
sh i'm doing a wedding or i'm going to a
wedding with the lady this weekend in uh
massachusetts at the cape you're taking
a weekend of stand-up off a couple days
and yeah i'll be back uh saturday so i
still got spots but
wow leaving tonight is it a friend of
yours hers but she was like block this
off she told me a year ago so it's
finally here
i'm sure you were furious when you got
there oh of course of course because
you're a [ __ ] and i think i got some
momentum going and then you're like oh
well yeah well you just taped something
so chill out for a minute good point
important important and you could just
get drunk and not think about it and
it's on the beach and it's the cape and
i'll be barefoot and hammer it i'm
thinking about the next special eye tape
and i'm like i'm i'm [ __ ] already
dreading taking a break
we like to work yeah yeah we have good
jobs so i need a break but i'm dreading
taking it i hear you it's like scary for
the [ __ ] to like hit you right we're
pushing i mean we're drinking on a
podcast we're putting some [ __ ] down i'm
sure of course i mean look at kevin hart
i mean the guy pumps out so much stuff
and you're like obviously you're running
from something i mean it's good at least
you're not doing heroin you're using it
in a good way but
there's a reason you're doing jumanji
nine
but
my point is the ninth one is where he's
a nervous breakdown he's like [ __ ]
when's this game end right right
but i'm going to massachusetts tonight
and
i have to pick up a rental car after
this so this is perfect time are you
[ __ ] kidding me but i will say i'm
the best drunk driver
i'm amazing
this episode gets stalled because
there's a new york post article comedian
mark norman pulled over well we just
talked about having footage why can't
she drive she can't drive i'm a better
drunk driver than she is driver i
[ __ ] you're it's still you should let
her drive well it's only four hours mark
what the [ __ ] you're pounding martinis
and you're gonna drive here's the thing
i'm gonna pick up the car park it do set
sober up have some coffee a diet coke a
gyro and then go gyro yeah soak it up i
love a gyro i love a gyro what do you
think when people say it's a hero well
cause hero's tough cause that's a whole
different thing that's what i say new
york we already have a hero yeah exactly
i will be your hero baby
um but yeah it's andrew cuomo
[Laughter]
yeah so i'll be driving a kia soul in
about one hour
yeah but i'll tell you if i
it's kind of like in in new york you get
bar mitzvahed we get duis you get a dui
you're 13 you knock it out you're a man
now you have a dui oh yeah who doesn't i
don't
really well i can't really drive oh yeah
good point really but do i yeah but it's
been expunged i think i got rid of it i
was so young
i is that a phone book
just got to make sure that's not on your
first google uh page but you're
successful enough i bet it's not well
you know it's weird i did a car
commercial for comedy central for toyota
camry yeah and they were like you don't
have a dui dude and i was like nah no no
and they let me drive it was super cool
brooklyn bridge we had uh all these
cameras on me i was driving the car text
jerry meet me i got this great gig this
is you can it's on youtube you can find
this it's literally like i don't know
10 years ago and
the commercial came out and they're like
wait we found out you have a dui and i'm
like yeah what are you gonna do and it
was fine it was fun i mean it was
already out i got away with it wait we
[ __ ] them yeah exactly
i made good
we got the commercial in the can yeah i
got a dui but it's fine
well done that's really the secret is
you know
always lie to the industry yes because
what does it matter exactly do you have
a new hour you have a clean hour yeah i
got a clean house always save a clean
hour always then you show up at the
temple and they're like what the [ __ ]
was that and you're like yeah just shut
up and pay me right right you do your
third 9 11 joke like jesus my dad uh
you're like i was
not one jew in the building
the best is when you're doing a
corporate and as you're walking to the
stage you're like remember clean and
you're like go [ __ ] yourself you can't
tell me on my walk to the stage i know i
remember i did a gig for uh an insurance
company in uh at the schomburg improv oh
a big room noise big and i was on like
painkillers and [ __ ] cause my back and
neck were out
and i went to the stage like [ __ ] uh
i was literally walking like the
undertaker like uh you know and i
remember on stage just [ __ ] trying to
survive yeah and yeah it's like she's
like there's like no language
restrictions i go up there and she's
like well i didn't mean that she was
freaking out i always say that and i was
like i by the way the funny thing is i'm
clean i'm working clean like up top and
it's getting desilch and then i was like
let me try this dick sucking joke and it
annihilates i'm like well guess what i'm
doing
exactly guess which bits i'm doing now
and don't you want an entertaining
comedian or do you want me to bomb it
doesn't make any sense you'd rather the
dick jokes
they'd rather we bomb and they protect
themselves so they could be like i'll
never do that again good point good
point we'll never book that guy again
yeah but as a comic you're like i'd like
to entertain the audience here this
[ __ ] pineapple
naked i said what are you doing he said
you came home early all right that's a
class i gotta get another rodney joke i
do that one every time that's a great
joke that's a great joke i'll tell you
my mother never breastfed me she told me
she'd like me as a friend
no respect
he's the greatest the greater timeless
jokes he's the i think ronnie
dangerfield's the funniest human being i
don't think he might be because he has
everything he's got the look the jokes
the tie
the face did this [ __ ] he's got the
catchphrase he's got it all oh so many
good i mean back to school really is the
funniest movie ever oh yeah there's
something funny about a guy just i'm
going all in on this character like i am
this guy like larry the cable guy is
clearly a character this is like i am
this i've become this thing
all the time
yeah he's perfect man i love it i gotta
pee for you too oh please so i got it's
all bathroom related i have multiple
ones only in the bathroom public
bathrooms you ever have that person who
both kind of hit the bathroom at the
same time and you kind of like all right
you go first yeah and they take forever
yeah
like i just gave you the green light you
should be and you [ __ ] just took 10
minutes and yeah and you know i'm out
here i did it it's that one's tough i
hate that and then uh
i what i want to do when they do that
[ __ ] is just as they walk out just hold
up a timer
just give them just a real just right in
their face this is what you [ __ ] did
yeah after i was kind
i know he might that must have been a
[ __ ]
i was it was a it was a woman with her
baby so maybe
that's why i let him go first like this
is more important
women and children first titanic rules
for the bathroom i will give you that
yeah
oh man
but i i guess a woman with a kid is a
she probably peed then the baby has to
change then you put the powdered
herself then she uh listened to a
podcast
i don't know no that is [ __ ] up yeah
but how could you not let her go i mean
it's a lady what do you have to do a
lady plus baby what am i supposed to do
if it was just a lady i probably would
have let her go of course even though
you guys take longer yeah let's be real
we go we give women
everything with the bathroom oh the
scene is always there i get scolded for
leaving the seat down yep i mean
for leaving it up yes same that's why i
i have mastered peeing with the seat
down and i never i never hit it how do
you how do you master i got amazing aim
i just really
if i do hit it i wipe it up steph curry
from the outside yes
i'm dick curry i just never miss the the
bowl the water do you ever just just sit
on it i've done that yeah middle of the
night i do a six i like to keep the
lights out yeah
i don't want the lights going on so i'll
sit middle of the night because i just i
don't wanna
the lights are out i want to stay sleepy
that's a great nickname for you sam
lights out morel
that's a good basketball day lightsaber
even though the only the only the fans
know it's about you urinating like a
woman wow lights out how to get that
name
he sits on the toilet larry dave had a
bit about that
i sit down when i pee and jeff was like
you sit down when you pee he's like yeah
i read he's like you read he's like i
pee 11 times a day i get through a whole
new york times
you know what i i really i remember that
episode i relate to that yeah i don't
sit down every time i pee but like yeah
sometimes i'll sit down why not i if
it's during the day i usually stand but
middle of the night how do you not pee
i just i'm just i get over it i i put
legs around the bowl now [ __ ]
actually slater that [ __ ] yes i do damn
you're like you're like [ __ ] your
toilet yeah i am i'm [ __ ] the toilet
i jizz in the toilet sometimes i've done
it all right better than the palm i
guess you got that right
palm pilot over here
my god that still irks me that irks you
yeah
the palm ah palm springs
oh my god you ever shoot one into the
sink oh yeah sings perfect height
and you're tall you're probably hitting
the medicine cabinet yeah we got we got
a crusty mirror
i look like the elephant man when i take
a look
why is the faucet sticky
that's like a dice type of it why is it
sticky shut up
oh little miss muffet
just in the sink oh
i put one on the stink
that's my dice a new dice bit that's a
guy who's a little kooky i mean he
talked about staying in character yeah
that's a character
he does it like uh at the supermarket oh
yeah he's a [ __ ]
he's at kroger's shoe i'm in the dumb in
the aisle right they're just
sorry we're just trying to check you out
yeah i'm looking for pineapple oh
that's a good pull with the kroger
because they don't have those here oh
yeah you went regional i went regional
good for you oh what the hell where is
kroger they have kroger in cleveland
i think he's from cleveland is he let's
hit the wendy's
dude
oh damn just like a wendy's employee i
got lots of bathroom per peeves okay
give me another one you ever do a unisex
bathroom yeah it's it's cleveland kroger
we go to uh
you'll use the unisex bathroom and you
go in first thank you dad you go in
first now i'm saying and then you come
out
but like someone you go in but someone
took a [ __ ] god-awful dump in there
so then you come out you pee and someone
gives you a look like thanks oh
yeah
i feel like harrison ford and the
fugitive like it wasn't me why are you
doing this to me
[Laughter]
yeah it was a one-armed man he shut his
brains out
that's uh that's uh i mean louie has a
bit about that that's a what what's his
biggest well
thank you it was on fx where
uh he's waiting for the bathroom big j
goes in
shits it up and then some other guy goes
in and skips louie and then he comes out
and he's like gee what you doing there
louie's like no i've been in yet it was
it was on the show yeah it's a louie
yeah it was on the show interesting yeah
that's that's a real thing
happens in the airport airplane a lot
when they got you there's two bathrooms
you know that's a tough one man yeah
i've never [ __ ] in an airplane bathroom
never i never have to [ __ ] an
airplane never come up coffee nut that's
why oh that's what it is i i go through
coffees just to stay alert airport oh
[ __ ] but airplane i don't know it ain't
pleasant no the knees sometimes i have
to sit down to piss in those air i'm
sick three i mean you're getting that
tiny little thing oh yeah i turned to
the hunchback of notre dame
don't get me started on you ever pee on
a bus
i mean it's like it's a [ __ ] core
workout yeah
it really is this is greyhound or p90x
it's true i mean something about that
bus it's just
you just wiggling them because they're
they're swerving on i-98 and you're like
peeing all over the place it's like
backdraft or the firehose
it's tough it's brutal i hate i hate
buses i took them for sure yeah i've
been doing gigs
i puked in so many [ __ ] bus oh same
those hung over rides
it's funny when you're hungover and
puking you're all over that rim
you know you're just like i don't care
anymore [ __ ] it you got your forearms up
there
your face is in the water and you're
like who gives a [ __ ] i'm i'm soaking up
feces and i don't give a [ __ ] i pray
noah yes exactly left over your face is
in the [ __ ] toilet ugh hey wait what
is this
what is this it's me keeping you under
the limit if you're driving ah what is
it that's a tonic water with just like a
tiny tiny cor even not even a quarter
ounce of comparison for color
but is there liquor in here just like i
said
a quarter house damn for the best mark i
hate to lose the martine that was so
good
you could have told me man no i want to
play ball here this is why driving's
stupid
still still my job to keep you in the
limit thank god they don't breathalyze
at the avis
public transit for life hell yeah
yeah look at marcus and mark saying they
don't breathalyze the avis meanwhile he
[ __ ] stumbles in yeah
sir maybe we're not gonna rent you this
car this is arthur three i'm doing
oh [ __ ] arthur is the best oh why did we
make that movie they almost remade back
to school oh is that right why are you
remaking a movie you gotta if you remake
it you gotta make it different you can't
just remake a movie and then just say
helen mirren is john gigliot that's not
different enough no these cowards in
hollywood they're too scared to try a
new movie but don't you realize we got
arthur arthur was new so you do a new
thing that's a [ __ ] great movie right
the first half of that movie is all
stand up when he's sitting there with a
hooker it's he just jokes he rolls down
the window jokes joe it's all jokes i'm
a hooker oh i'm sorry i thought i was
just doing really well with you
great jokes dudley moore man
yeah he's a beast killer i mean did he
do much else
well what other classic deadly morning
movies he was in elijah he was in a lot
of [ __ ] oh he was in that christmas
movie he was an elf and something yeah
he ruled he was a drunk right oh yeah oh
yeah i think he was like 5-1 too he's
like a little guy why isn't benelli's
great in that movie john giggled i think
won the oscar for it
i don't know but i don't know maybe it
was a huge movie when it came out yeah
and that's fun you get old new york
shots in that too which i love speaking
of seinfeld dads we got jerry's dad in
that movie that's right that's right
yeah yeah old new york cop by the way
was he yeah he was a cop turned actor
same with dennis farina oh really yeah
whoa farina's underrated so underrated
give him a goog at home
one of my faves so good he's so good in
a midnight run he's a villain
he's so good i mean he was either a
criminal or a cop yeah he's not on order
later in his career totally what else is
he in he's in [ __ ] everything he's in
a ton of movies he's a great character
actor
damn he was a legend legend so funny
great delivery great boys great look
yeah he's great and gets shorter get
shorty's underrated too love get shorty
that's another one they remade
well tv for tv it was pretty good though
oh was it well if you're doing a tv show
which is different because you you can
go to a deeper place
tv shows i'm fine with you doing
a movie version of because
it's like
if it's look at like fargo it's not the
movie fargo you just took the tone of
fargo and made through the show and the
show's good the show is good i'm just
saying if you're gonna do the exact same
[ __ ] movie and it's like when
i love gus van sant no disrespect to gus
van samp
when he did a
shot for shot remake of psycho it's like
well what's the point of this you're
just doing the shot for shot remake in
color yeah
i know i like that i i liked that bomb
because it i'm not it's like a cover
song
we got it already
if you cover it cover it differently yes
do something like do something like
cover sea of love the way tom waits did
it ah and that way i'm like okay this is
a different song right
good point good point there's a couple
great covers out there
rarely is the cover better than the
original but sometimes it happens
yeah what's a cover that's better than
the original i bet you could give that a
goog
covers that are better covers that are
better than the original it's rare but
they're out there there's the uh
guns and roses knocking on heaven doors
pretty damn good
that's true it's not better than the
stones no it's up stones
who didn't ever
i thought it was the beatles wasn't the
best maybe you're right it might have
been the stones
ah
knocking on heaven's door i've been
drinking
i think tainted love has been covered
like
a million times that original sucked
i hate that song but guns and roses
well who's the original
oh man
give us uh he's looking at porn out
there his match dick is out it's
disgusting matt
[Laughter]
give us uh covers that are better than
the original because that's to me
interesting yeah i think they're out
there uh johnny cash hurt
wait who's the original nine-ish nails
right
no i think cash is better
i think cash is better too
but who so nina's nails covered it no no
he
cash didn't come up with that song who
did i think they're not in snails right
no
cash is 800 years old but he covered it
when he was old as [ __ ] oh wait i'm
confused all right
this guy's got a microphone from the um
aol days what's going on over here you
gotta get you got 18 mics in here you
kick it you got to get yourself one
look at that thing we're out of [ __ ]
one train what the hell is going on
uh
i gotta give you a peeve yeah
oh that's guys you'll get it while we're
doing it all right
here's a peeve
and this is from a guy we know he he
does this [ __ ] all the time because he
wants to look cool i think i hate to
look cool yeah so i'm sitting with this
guy
and it's kind of just me and him so
we're like i know it's amazing so i'm
like all right let me make some
conversations so i'm trying to be nice
and converse and and make small talk and
i go hey i saw an intern didn't you do a
uh a college gig on monday and he goes
what no
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't know where
i got i thought i saw you doing a
college gig what was i thinking it was
on long island on monday he was like no
what are you talking about i'm like ah
[ __ ] i don't know what i was thinking
and i go i thought you did a college gig
guys yeah that was tuesday and i'm like
all right so i i i had everything right
but the day and you're acting like i'm
that was the day
yeah
exactly like
oh you had a college gig on monday he's
like no did you cheat on me
are you cheating me on monday no
are you [ __ ] kidding me exactly i
cheated on you on monday tuesday yeah
yeah i cheated on you on tuesday yes
exactly i was like okay you act like i
[ __ ] uh called your mom a [ __ ] and i
had the day wrong but could you meet me
halfway and go yeah i did do a college
gig wasn't that
i would just go yeah yeah i did it was
awesome or it was sucked
to just go no like yeah he looked at me
like i was crazy that's [ __ ] that's a
huge peeve
you know what i mean
people are not meeting you halfway
that's the peace like right you know
what we're doing here yeah don't be too
[ __ ] cool for school the guy who
relishes in the [ __ ] up you know like
you get some guy from nebraska he comes
out here and he goes excuse me sir he's
got a big map out he's got a plaid shirt
on and shorts and he goes where is a
houston street you're not gonna go i
don't know oh he there is no houston
street no you're gonna go oh it's it's
houston but it's a block away and that's
the end of it but to like relish in the
[ __ ] up i hate that wha what did you
just say yes houston street yes hey
honey get a load of this guy he just
said houston street exactly what the
[ __ ] up you know what he meant that's
all i'm saying that drives me nuts yeah
and uh the dick move it's a dick move i
yeah i don't like people
they're too cool for school move dude i
i can't have another one of these
are you making me a third i'm gonna be
[ __ ] hammered
trust me i want boy we killed the whole
bottle basically
it's only 10 ounces all right
it sounds cooler does that kill the
bottle
when we have a bigger bottle we'll make
sure to kill the bottle i will bring the
bigger bottle it's sitting on my coffee
table i [ __ ] up there we go
full bottle that's how we do it yeah you
[ __ ] up i'm not mad at you though it
happens well
he pulled it together thank god you put
it together you're the glue yes you're
the dream on green of this here pause
just don't snap on us
that guy's got a temper
i love that guy by the way there's a new
uh
malice in the palace you watch that wait
man it's out oh it's out
yeah oh yeah i was alex english our
buddy was uh at that game
as a kid
whoa they were in the crowd man what was
that 0-5
0-8 before maybe
it was something like that it was the
that year the pacers were good enough to
win it and the pistons i think won or i
don't but something like that maybe the
spurs won that year but like
the pacers were [ __ ] locked and they
were rocking reggie miller oh yeah he
should be pissed because that was like
he was old on that team he still played
he's old and they had run our tests and
who was like the guy who started that
yeah but i love our test the new york
guy you you love him i mean he's like a
you saw that doc on him i did yeah
badass he's a special guy too he's got
mental health stuff but he's a special i
wrote apart from him in this show i made
i i i hope i make it someday whoa
he was like basically like
it's basically a guy who gets cancelled
and he's his sponsor because he can't do
it and i'm a pretty fun part i love her
on our test man this is a great
great moment in that in the malice in
the palace where uh
you know one guy threw a beer on him
that's what started everything yeah and
so ron artest goes out into the crowd
and just hits a guy but he hit the wrong
guy
and then they interview the guy they're
like did you feel bad when he hit
someone else and not you and the guy
goes
no i was relieved
this giant guy so honest yeah it was a
great great comedy moment so you've
watched this it i saw the probably the
first half but it's fun and you liked it
it's great it's great even if even if
you're not a huge basketball guy i just
like the way they put those
documentaries together and i can get in
anything my mission will be to get you
into basketball i mean i do like it i
went to a knicks game i was i was
on the edge of my seat the whole time i
love it man nick's till i die man
all day but uh not a nets guy huh no way
all right i resp i love the players
individually like i think durant is like
a [ __ ] they put him up there with the
greats he's incredible i hard and kyrie
they're just like
and it's like
insane how good they all are yeah it's i
can't not think that they're special and
i love them but like i'm a knicks fan
until i [ __ ] died dude yeah well
here's my thing about athletes
randall's my favorite player i love
really all the time
right now right is my favorite player
all the time
starks ewing oakley mace those are my
favorite players spreewell
but uh do you go into the personal life
are you just talking about the physical
play oh i just love how they play yeah i
mean like and then like reading the
books i love the 70s next like the
they were like this team of guys who
i mean to be a mixed race team in the
60s and have the best chemistry is like
kind of powerful that is cool you know
like walt clyde frazier and willis reed
and willis reed hobbling onto the court
on one like this before twitter so in
the championship he couldn't walk and
everyone's like he's done wow and he
[ __ ] hobbled on the court and played
to be like i'll [ __ ] energize the
team and
to this day every article is like it's
the loudest any buildings wow cause to
see him come out they were like this is
heroic i'm getting chills yeah and then
uh and then walt frazier who's like my
[ __ ] favor he's just the coolest he's
the broadcaster now but he's
he won two championships the knicks it's
our only two championships ever 69 70 72
73 or only two championships 50 [ __ ]
years man yeah that's a dude but uh
you know frasier went off for like
i think it was like 36 points 19 assists
insane game to win the championship over
the lakers and uh
willis reed just played like two he
played like two plays he came out and
hit the first two shots and he couldn't
walk so they sub them out but just him
playing gave the knicks the energy to do
it wow so cool wait a minute i mean
ignorant stupid
non-sport guy question
what do you think it is
i mean one one sentence answer why is
there a 50-year gap we got this amazing
city with all these amazing with money
who can get good players get good
coaches
maybe the best arena in in america what
is it we can't
bang it out hiring the wrong people for
a long time i mean what happened with
here's what happened the 70s we won
80s we just weren't good 83 draft
patrick ewing then uh that but we get
ewing who's incredible he's like the
number one pick it was insane that we
got the number one people consider they
call it rig that new york it's the
number one pick even though we never
[ __ ] get it
and then uh the 90s we get to go against
jordan so it's like bad timing
you know it's like no one beat jordan
right but what about 2005 to now
a lot of problems a lot hiring a lot of
the wrong people in the front office a
lot a lot of issues yeah it's tough man
you see the yankees i know it's a
different sport but there's no salary
cap in baseball
you can you can
i mean
you look at all these like forbes like
highest ranked franchises and the knicks
are always in the top five even though
we never and we're the only team in the
top five that doesn't win that's what
i'm saying of any sport
well because people we're starved new
york's a basketball city because you go
to every block and you're like there's a
[ __ ] court every three blocks in the
city it's a basketball city so
uh there's a lot of basketball city
chicago sure you know california is you
know a lot of great players coming to la
a lot of
a lot of great players coming out of
texas a lot of players come from all
over but uh
it's in this [ __ ] cities like dna i
know that's why it's so
and i know obviously drafting comes from
all over but like we'll get good again
it just takes time man all right we got
good people now i'm a psycho i'm a
psycho fan
i like that because a lot of people will
fall off when they're not winning no i
[ __ ] i go harder good because that's
when you fall off you show your true
colors when things are bad man you'll
never get a divorce
no matter how bad it gets just staying
in there
you know you're like 50 years we'll get
another ring these glasses are great by
the way look at that isn't that cool
well these were a gift from someone i
don't know where they came from did we
get a did we get a cover
all right matt fell asleep but we got we
got all these we should read this this
one we should plug this wine that people
said we got to drink this one episode
when we don't have a bartender we know
if dan will drink this right here argyle
i got this blonde blonde
the white of whites which is what i call
my album
but uh they called charlottesville
yeah this looks like good you know what
it's sparkling wine 100 chardonnay from
oregon but they say champagne it's got
to be from champaign france
huh you ever heard that
i don't know i don't love champagne
really i don't it's just like for me
it's like a huge hangover i mean look
good i just prefer if i'm going to be
hungover i'd rather have i like wine a
lot
yeah i'm a wino man wine's funny you do
like wine it's fun to get [ __ ] up on
wine white
i go red usually yeah see i find that
hangover to be bad too
red wine is fun as hell i find that uh
it's a good drunk it's a little loopy
goofy fun it's my favorite i mean like
bourbon
i love i love a good martini i love
bourbon whiskey i love
i go wine over beer personally
i like beer beer is great but like if
i'm gonna get [ __ ] up i'm like i want
i want to get i'm gonna drink a lot of
wine all right all right i wish i liked
i like a white
but uh red in the winter is just like
man it's like a cold night out you just
have a [ __ ] bottle you're just
getting hammered yeah i love that it
looks good it looks good just
some about it's too thick i love beer
too i just something about wine no i get
it i get i'm the weirdo every lady likes
wine every every guy i know my parents
love wine i just wine is just uh
it's a good drunk like it is a good
drink like i value it's not just the
taste but like how it makes you feel and
you get a good uh you get a good buzz
going very it's a sexy buzz too
do you like wine
i like certain types of wine
i would love to convert you into wine
drinker hey try me i i want to get into
it it's everywhere i think you would
like just some assemble like a dry
riesling which is nice like a dry white
no i'm i'm on board with his
girlfriend's also a dry white
that's fine it's all labels yeah what do
you got on there uh i figured i'd
broaden your wine horizons and get you
to stop drinking that natural wine stuff
this is the real deal anytime you have
any wine questions you have a certified
sommelier a text away wow i have pin so
it's official
i don't know what pin is that some kind
of certification
i don't
yeah
well uh this is my buddy craig who uh he
was my camp counselor when i was a
little kid and he stayed he stayed in
touch that's adorable yeah yeah he's a
great guy i love craig he uh jews love
camp
yeah we took back the way the word the
way black people took back the word the
n word we took back cam
[Laughter]
write that down
that's big but no he was if i could say
camp i remember he chased me around the
bunk once we were sweeping duties we had
like you know duties to sweep and uh he
got really mad at me once he chased me
all over and i ran with the broom and i
ran through the door with it
horizontally and i just knocked my
window oh
man another time same counselor uh
wholesome fun
another time i jumped off a dam wow i
landed on a rock
and he was like i'm gonna get fired what
happened i was okay i think it was like
a sprained ankle or something i landed
like very luckily you were going for the
water yeah wow
damn that's wild yeah
that's my biggest nightmare you know
when people jump off the cliff or
whatever and then they're like dude your
head was an inch away from a rock ah
or maybe there's a rock an inch below
the water you just didn't see i'm not
like i'm like i'm good with all that
stuff i'm i we take enough risks in our
life yeah i flying every week i'm like
one of these has got to go down
the odds
they're against us and then you're like
how you don't hear a lot of plane
crashes anymore no no
whatever the hell that was yeah
sheetrock
yeah but malaysia
it feels like planes disappear
did we ever find that malaysian i know
it's like there's like a hack bit from
14 years old i think it just it's gone i
think yeah when you don't hear from it
it's like it doesn't go into that be a
great that's the new amazon prime show
right they're like the people from the
malaysian plane in another dimension
yeah
yeah i mean that's why i bermuda
triangle bit that never worked it's like
it was just a scary thing and now we
fixed it i guess yeah
but hey we are brought to you by sheath
underwear this keeps your ball off your
leg two pouches one for your dick one
for your balls keeps the ammo separate
from the gun this is great underwear i
actually use this this is my
girlfriend's favorite underwear this
gets me laid this underwear supportive
sexy looking i really do this is my
favorite underwear i'm not just saying
this i'm not just saying this because
they're paying us money i really think
there's quality underwear
uh the idea from sheath came from the
founder us army soldier robert padden
during his second tour in iraq are you
guys going to support the troops or what
support this awesome veteran-owned
company who's founder he's a big comedy
fan he's messaged me he's a great dude i
know he's messaged you too go to sheath
underwear dot com and order with promo
code drunk to get 20
off your first order and sheath
underwears 100
money back guarantee that sheath
underwear dot com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls do we have you have a wreck
this week oh yeah i got a couple
actually hit me you got a million peeves
i got a million wrecks i don't know if i
have any wrecks right now here we go
i don't know where you stand on this uh
oh look what's coming at you oh baby
he's just putting it there wow you reach
for that thing quick no hesitation that
was awesome i'll tell you
here's a wreck i give my doctor a urine
sample and all of it
i don't want to say my ex-wife was fat
but uh her belly button had an echo
um
here's a wreck
get an electric toothbrush everybody oh
yeah yeah i love them gotta do it i
brushed my teeth for 18 minutes joel is
like what are you doing you get an
electric you knock it out in four
seconds hit every tooth
it's great great for you oral b electric
charge it every night you're good to go
damn that was my nickname in prison oral
b
but i uh yeah i know i love a uh i love
an electric toothbrush game changer i lo
you got one oh it's oh yeah that's for
you
i got one for my girlfriend now she was
like i'm not into it at first and i was
kind of like are you [ __ ] kidding me
really she kind of was like this is just
like i don't like how it feels in my
teeth and uh now she's never looked back
whoa
yeah no they're just better you it's
they're not even that expensive anymore
no they're cheap but i've never put i'm
like bob dylan i'm acoustic we found
like we're like uh this sounds like
we're compromised after this wreck this
sounds like we're in like partnership
with big dental or something also you
know you guys my wreck is flossing
those little picks yeah
it is it is but apparently not as
everybody's like you gotta floss every
day apparently it's like once a week
it's fine really that's what the the new
studies are saying depends how much you
eat corn i guess yeah yeah corn and pork
if i eat barbecue it's all in the cracks
good barbecue man i'll be in i'll be in
can uh well no actually that's st louis
st louis coming up i'll be in uh they've
great barbecue i'll be yeah missouri's
got legit barbecue for sure yeah oh yeah
that was uh my nickname in college dry
rub
but
i don't even know what that means but
yeah
get some barbecue get it get an oral b
and uh get your teeth cleaned what about
you what do you gotta wreck wreck i
don't know if i have one this week man
i've been watching a lot of [ __ ] you
know what i got a wreck actually uh-huh
i'm such a big fan of tim robinson
oh everybody's raving about you watching
you should leave i've never watched it
oh i think he's like i love sam
richardson too who they so my wreck i i
think you should leave you should
definitely watch on netflix i'm watching
detroiters man
god damn they're funny together they're
just [ __ ] matt have you seen this
[ __ ] everybody's raving
i mean it's just pure fun the episodes
are like 15 minutes it's just it's just
fun dude there's a couple i'm text with
my boy phil hanley and phil's like
there's a sloppy stakes episode in the
second season that's all you need to
know all right and like phil's like
that's the hardest i think i've ever
laughed like it's it's and it got me so
hard like i was
like
sorry
i'm a child but
i'm gonna watch i was dying dude if you
two like it i'll check it out it's
really good
it's really fun everybody on twitter
people i respect are like this show is
amazing it's amazing so funny it's like
any sketch show like it's hit or miss
and no sketch show bass a thousand but
when it hits it hits on another level
because his commitment is
i love tim robinson yeah that guy rules
no he's great he's great and such a
funny
looking guy like he just looks when you
see him you're like this guy is funny
it's he does the way sandler did [ __ ] in
the 90s where it was like he would
commit to just being a lunatic yes like
he'd be like just screaming and you'd be
howling as a kid yeah it's that type of
funny okay he's found like a new type of
character right
right well he just will [ __ ] with people
like it's it's it's almost like he
it's a great inspiration where you're
like oh i need to follow my gut on stuff
with stand-up even i mean because like
he'll take such a small minute thing and
stretch it to the limit
all right i'll check it out people are
raving i think he's awesome and uh
yeah he's the best all right and it's
it's on netflix i think you should leave
us on netflix and uh detroiters is on
the i think the comedy central app maybe
paramount plus so good luck with that
one but yeah i'm watching it and i'm
loving it all right loving it i'm in i'm
in i'm gonna check it out
good wreck yeah good day now uh jeez i
don't know how long we've been oh we
gotta do a bit
yeah are we going long what time is that
i think we're right on time
you know yeah
uh let's see bit bit well you got
something i have an idea so i think this
could maybe be stretched further did i
ever try this bit on you hit me about uh
it's the problem with this podcast we
drink so i don't know what the hell i
said before where i am but uh so i just
bit about how like
first off i was talking to a friend and
he was like trying to he was you know i
was trying to sound progressive about
the trans thing and he was like look man
i get i'll play along i'm like you're
not as progressive as you think so yeah
i'll play along right i don't think
they're grateful that you're like yeah
you're a woman wink wink i'm playing
along here you know what i mean right so
that's one part of it the other part is
like how i just think that's a whole i
think i love the idea of being like no i
get it i'll play along right you're not
i'm on to you they're not they're not
grateful for that comment
but also uh but made me laugh and then
also that's funny the thing about like
i get
uh trans people because uh
with this voice i identify as a much
stronger man
you know what i mean like i like i i
should not be this cowardly right
i should be in a much stronger manner oh
that's good that's yeah i mean yeah yeah
you're six three you got the deepest
voice hairy chest like hairy chest is
what they say like that'll put hair on
your chest it's like a manly thing yeah
and you're like i can't even drive yeah
you know i'm not a man well that's funny
you identify
you come off as a man well i do all the
things men do i think i mean i drink i
don't drive though so well yeah you're
very manly you drink and drive
that's true i combine them yeah
no no i like that that's funny
so would you identify as not a man or
maybe you look like a man but identify
as not maybe on paper for the most part
i can't fix it though though you know
yeah i think i think on a superficial
level though like he's a man but i'm not
yeah it's like how people go you look
like a man you're like no but i identify
as a woman you're like well you look
like a man you're like i identify as as
a
as a boy i identify as a weakling yeah
there you go no uh ability to fix things
yeah
yeah
oh that's good i identify as a man who
needs to call maintenance a lot right
right
yeah that's the real you what do you got
that's you inside
ah this could be horrible
uh this is a stretch of a bit because
we're we're doing these back to back so
i didn't feel like i i really had a lot
of time to come up with this but i think
i got something here and feel free to
shoot this down
my friend is his hair is receding really
bad but he's in denial about it like his
girlfriend's like oh maybe you should
get
rogaine or keeps or one of those things
and he's like nah i'm fine and he almost
sounds like a guy
who is
in denial about climate change uh it's
like he's losing coastline it's like the
facts are there like you can see photos
like here's a photo of a glacier in 88
and here's a photo of a glacier now and
then it's the same with his hair like
look at you in 88
it goes back an inch every year it's
your your ice caps are melting and he
still won't believe it wow is that
anything
it's interesting it's a bit of a leap i
get it but no it's like climate change
the the the proof is there i like that
the proof is there but he still won't
buy it
and wait
it's such a climate change denier when
it's the person who's most affected by
climate change that's right right
because it's like
right it's missing something no but the
fact that it's
it's like you're like if uh the southern
coast of florida was like this isn't
real
right with your airline right yeah yeah
yeah like uh ah it's tough because
i thought about something maybe with
like the hair
you know people say like don't people
like it hotter and people go well don't
people like it bald
don't women like bald guy i don't know
maybe there's something there but some
women like bald guys but uh
yeah yeah yeah it's a kind of it's a
pretty high concept and a bit of a
stretch but
he sounds just like a denier
yeah you won't
like you could still you know it's like
why don't we do something why don't we
recycle and you're like why don't you
get rogaine he's like nah that ain't
real either way they might just be lazy
that might be the core of uh-huh why
don't you recycle yeah it'll work itself
out you're like it's not i'm looking at
you you need to get yourself a mirror
right right
yeah
yeah i don't know what would it would
have climate change deniers say maybe if
he believes in the climate maybe he
believes that it's a problem coming up
oh so he believes in that yeah we need
to do something about this and she's
like we need you something about this
that might be actually easier to see
this affects
this affects me right now right climate
change will affect your kids this could
this could make everything wet she's
like i'm definitely not wet ah
see when i did it to the crowd i could
tell they were like ah
what do you mean i don't know where it's
not it's not a short swing yet yes
i need to make it simplify so that might
be a better way yeah like
he's worried about that but not this
yeah one of them is is now
the other one is gonna be bad
i don't know
it's an idea text me if you got an idea
i get all these nice there's something
there for sure yeah i finally got the
old man hungover thing working so
there's been a few that i've tried on
here that are working the engagement
they killed last night yeah i got some
new [ __ ] hidden there uh
so everything's good man it just takes a
minute with these bits yeah people at
home don't know how hard it is to write
new material it's tough because i'm i'm
working on other stuff now too you know
we do this we you know you have your
other podcasts i have another podcast
right we uh be writing a show we're
working on it yeah working on a lot of
stuff so it's hard and then you know
we're tired a lot from just travel so i
think like your bra and yeah i'm sure
the booze is not helping but it does
help also sometimes you need to shut
down that's true you got to turn off
it's like a computer you leave it on too
much you're like this is going slow yes
same with the brain every once in a
while you gotta shut down whether it be
a drink or five
uh
call of duty whatever [ __ ] you do yeah
exactly you play video games
uh no i'm not a video game guy and i'm
glad i'm not yeah because i got hooked
on candy crush
for a while and
my girlfriend my ex-girlfriend at the
time was like you gotta stop like you
just sit there and i'll i'll be like oh
[ __ ] it's 5 a.m
and then you lose all the day because
you sleep all day so like is that fun
it's just fun and addictive and your
brain
it gets right in your head and i just
had to delete it off my phone i'm not
one of those guys who was like i had to
delete twitter i can shut that [ __ ] off
but candy crush i just kept going that
you're on the train you're on a plane
it's funny that you're like i have a
problem with candy crush i've literally
watched how much you drank and you've
never told me even the whole problem
yeah and you're like [ __ ] candy crush
man it got me mad me it got me and i and
this is you know 10 years ago but it got
me good and i just never played it since
i had to like go to rehab for candy
crush
should we plug dates yes
let's see i don't know this must come
out in what october we really backlogged
here
but uh no not this week in the following
one oh okay okay well i'm in uh
appleton this weekend skyline
haven't been there in years i don't even
remember what it's like i'll be in
michigan i'll be right back close to you
i'll be involved this weekend so there
you go yeah wisconsin nashville west
palm beach new orleans going home to see
the folks uh
uh now atlanta
um
portland madison wisconsin a lot of fun
dates come on by check it out praise oh
boston in providence royal oak michigan
this weekend at the uh comedy castle
laugh boston underrated club can't wait
uh punchline atlanta millersville
pennsylvania helium in philadelphia uh
moon tower in austin i got st louis uh
helium uh indianapolis helium blue room
in uh october i got [ __ ]
uh denver uh
nice so many so many weekends there's
someone i'm forgetting here
san francisco francisco's on sale for
cobbs in november
they were announcing something with the
new york comedy festival hey
uh maybe a live app who knows live up
who knows then we got uh
[ __ ] stand up live phoenix so much [ __ ]
i'm forgetting some but go to
samurail.com
shows oh and i'll see it redrock
speaking of denver with uh with bert
that'll be a banana
that's in like a month so that's that's
actually
september 8th
so that's coming that'll be here it's
around the corner then we're going to
jimmy buffett the next night dude that's
wild gonna be nuts but yeah comedy's fun
come on out don't kill yourself keep
drinking to the patreon
dot com slash we might be drunk and uh
email us we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com we read them on the patreon
you guys are sending us awesome packages
at gotham studios on 38th street thank
you to gotham studio thank you to matt
uh dan and best i mean we should have
had him plug something before he left
here oh yeah i mean he got us nice and
loose yeah
i forgot his last name but look up dan
he's a bartender we thanks for all the
tequila stuff jamie lynn and uh yeah
send it in we'll drink it we'll lead it
we'll talk about it
take it easy
[Music]
you